what we're trying to do in the
laboratory is to simulate a process that
we think was very common on the early
earth and it's still common today in
fact whatever rain falls on a volcano it
makes little puddles that are heated by
the volcanic energy when it stops
raining those puddles evaporates so we
have a wet/dry cycle occurring all the
time
yelling volcanic areas of the
present-day earth in the laboratory we
are simulating that by building a
chamber the chamber has got to be
anaerobic being there's can't be any air
in it because the oxygen in today's
chamber and in today's atmosphere will
damage the chemicals that we're trying
to work with so we are loading this
chamber up with a inert gas that happens
to be carbon dioxide but we could use
something like nitrogen if we wanted to
carbon dioxide is easy to use we have a
tank sort of blowing co2 into the
chamber and as the co2 comes into
contact with a reaction medium that we
are testing it dries it out we have the
equivalent of volcanic heat we have two
heaters under a big disc an aluminium
disc that is turning very slowly and
every vial that is embedded in this disc
and there's 24 of them goes through one
wet/dry cycle every 90 minutes so that's
what how we're simulating it we're
drying it out under a stream of carbon
dioxide where rehydrating was just plain
old water then it goes through another
drying cycle this occurs every 90
minutes and in a typical experiment
we'll have about four of these cycles in
a day that we will then analyze the
result and see what we've made if
anything